michael found adele in 1984 out of his
dorm room at the university of texas at
austin his small dorm room project
rapidly grew into a billion-dollar
conglomerate and by 1992 michael was the
youngest ceo to head a fortune 500
company in 2004 after leading the
company for 20 years michael decided
that it was time to step away and take
it easy but within just three years of
leaving dell lost the lead to hp they
lagged behind the market for the first
time in the company's history and the
sec was investigating dell for
accounting issues michael would return a
ceo in 2007 but most of his time would
simply be spent on damage control
in 2013 michael took dell private and
spent five years restructuring their
company against all odds when dell
became public once again they came back
stronger than ever before
so here's the bumpy story of dell and
why dell could not survive without
michael
to answer this question we have to take
a look at what made dell successful in
the first place when michael started
dell which was originally named pcs
limited he was by no means a big fish
nor was he early to the scene
in retrospect it may seem like 1984 was
super early to be jumping into the
personal computer business but it did
not feel that way at the time
ibm and the compaq were the industry
standard and companies like apple had
already leveraged the early mover
advantage so to attract customers
michael had to think outside of the box
and he came up with two major selling
points the first tactic was leveraging a
direct-to-consumer model computers were
extremely expensive in the 1980s the
apple ii for instance cost between one
thousand two hundred ninety eight
dollars and two thousand six hundred
thirty eight dollars that's the same as
fifty eight hundred to twelve thousand
dollars today
retailers weren't making the situation
any better as they were stuffing in
massive profit margins into each sale
the apple one for instance had a retail
markup of 33 percent seeing this michael
decided to advertise his company in
computer magazines and sell directly to
the customer in the early days almost
all of pc limited's orders came from
businesses and governments
and in an effort to increase customer
loyalty mica would implement a second
tactic which was unparalleled
customizability all of michael's
competitors were selling through
retailers meaning that they could only
produce a limited number of skus
producing too many skews would simply
result in major inventory issues
but for pcs limited given their direct
to customer business model they didn't
need to build a computer itself until
they received an order
at first michael used this tactic
because he needed revenue from the
customer in order to actually purchase
the parts used in the computer
but as the business grew michael made
this obstacle into an advantage anyway
michael would change the name of the
company to dell computer corporation and
take the company public in 1988 by the
end of 1988 dell's market cap would grow
to 80 million dollars and in 1992 dell
would be included in the fortune 500
list by this point that dell's business
with commercial customers was going
pretty well
so michael decided to expand the
business to retail customers
initially in 1993 michael chose the most
obvious route which was selling through
big box retailers it was estimated that
expanding to retailers would inflate
dale's revenue by 125 million dollars
however within a year of entering the
retail scene michael decided that big
bucks retailers were not the move
retailers not only made dell's margins
extremely thin but retailers were not
what made dell successful in the first
place for a while after exiting the
retail space michael struggled to figure
out how to effectively target retail
customers without the help of retailers
but in 1996 he landed on the jackpot
which was launching an online store
once again looking back it's obvious why
this was successful in 1996 though this
was a rather questionable move here's
the thing most retail pc buyers were
first-time computer buyers so how were
they supposed to use the internet to
order a pc if they didn't already have a
pc
sure they could go to an internet cafe
but most retail customers weren't too
familiar with pcs and they felt much
more comfortable buying a pc in person
with the help of a sales rep than trying
to figure it out by themselves online
these limitations reduced dell's reach
to basically just pc enthusiasts but
this was by design
first-time pc buyers were indeed the
fastest growing segment within the
market throughout the 1990s however
appealing to first-time pc buyers was a
race to the bottom
as computer manufacturers achieved
better economies of skill competition
for offering the cheapest pc became
fierce and cut throat
these guys were pulling in more revenue
than ever before but their profit
margins were also lower than ever before
in the meantime dell's average selling
price was actually going up though del's
demographic of pc enthusiasts was
relatively small these guys were
purchasing more and more powerful pcs
every time bolstering dell's financials
at the same time dell would expand into
one more major sector which was servers
dell was not early to this sector either
by the time dell entered the scene ibm
hp and compact dominated the server
market no one really challenged these
three as they had access to proprietary
technology and proprietary software
instead of seeing this as an obstacle
though michael treated this as an
advantage while ibm and hp were selling
their fancy high-end servers dell
decided to introduce low-end to cheap
servers that were simply based on intel
chips this of course did not appeal to
every corporation but dell was able to
find a niche portion of the market that
found dell's low end servers to be more
than enough dell launched their
poweredge servers in 1994 and within
four years of launch enterprise revenue
grew from nothing to 13 of their entire
revenue
michael actually had a rather infamous
quote around this time
in 1997 when apple was nearly bankrupt
reporters would ask michael what he
would do if he was in charge of apple
michael replied i'd shut it down and
give the money back to the shareholders
i'm sure that was easy to say given that
dell was killing it in the late 1990s
but we'll eventually see how michael
handles the situation himself
anyway given their rapid growth in all
of these sectors dell became the world's
largest pc manufacturer in 1999. as you
can see the one key attribute that is
present in each of those victories is
execution dell wasn't the first they
were never the best they weren't the
most innovative and they didn't have a
massive legacy however the one thing
dell did have was flawless execution
as we move into the 2000s though the
same cannot be said about their
execution
in 2002 dell would launch a wide array
of products which really made no sense
they launched tvs printers digital audio
players and other handheld devices
expanding into new categories and
diversifying your business is completely
fine
after all expansion is what allowed dell
to get to that position in the first
place however this expansion was
completely different from everything
they had already done
the difference was that there was no
strategy with the business computers
micro leveraged a direct-to-consumer
model with retail customers michael
levers the internet with servers michael
leveraged the underserved low-end market
but with these additions it was almost
as if dell was saying we're big and
established now so you should buy
whatever we put out
in 2003 dell would change their name
from dell computer corporation to just
dell inc
and in 2004 michael would resign as del
ceo and hand over the reins to kevin
rollins at the time the pc market was
starting to mature which led to a
sizeable decline in computer purchases
one segment of the market however was
still growing rapidly and this was
laptops dell didn't approach the laptop
market strategically like they always
did though they chose the easy route and
sold their laptops in big box retailers
which of course left them with little to
no differentiation and extremely their
profit margins somehow they fell into
the exact trap that they avoided a
decade ago sure enough eighty percent of
rollins quarterly reports would come in
below expectations and he would resign
as ceo in january of 2007 allowing for
michael to take on the position once
again
but things wouldn't just turn around
right after michael became ceo again you
see the company as a whole was facing an
internal crisis a company survey found
that 50 of their employees would be
willing to leave the company for a
comparable job elsewhere
this was because of two primary reasons
dell had become more bureaucratic than
ever before under the leadership of
roland's and many employees hated this
the second reason was that thousands of
employees had become quite wealthy
thanks to stock options combined with
the dotcom bubble it's estimated that
dell minted 2 700 million years and
dozens of these guys had made tens of
millions fun fact dell had made so many
millionaires that people call these
individuals billionaires the problem
though was that these guys were just
working at dell for fun at this point
and they didn't really care about the
future of the company or getting fired
as a result mica would launch a campaign
called dell 2.0 the goal of the campaign
was to get rid of all of the complacent
employees and managers and return to the
roots of what made dell great however as
michael focused on changing the
company's culture in the late 2000s and
the early 2010s he missed out on the
unstoppable rise of tablets and
smartphones and this just left dell in
an even worse position by 2013
the company wasn't about to go bankrupt
but they were tumbling down a steep
cliff between 2012 and 2013 those
earnings per share crashed from 36 cents
to just seven cents the next obvious
step was negative earnings and
eventually bankruptcy
now michael didn't shut down dell like
he recommended steve jobs do
but he would technically return all the
money to the shareholders in 2013
michael made a deal with the private
equity firm and microsoft to cough up
the 24.4 billion dollars required to
take dell private shareholders were
pretty pleased with this deal as michael
was buying a shares for 25 premium and
they didn't have much hope for dell
anyway
as expected dell's profits continued to
tumble and dell would lose 1.2 billion
by 2015
but this would all change in october of
2015 when dell made a deal with a
company called emc
emc was a giant in the realms of data
storage data analytics and cloud
computing dell would buy emc for 67
billion dollars which was mostly funded
by debt though this deal crowned dell in
debt the acquisition allowed dell to not
only make up lost time in the cloud and
database markets but become the dominant
player in the enterprise market since
then dell has clung on to the enterprise
market and this has been the backbone
support indel's recovery over the past
five years
so why was dell not able to survive
without michael
well the answer is complacency
everyone from the employees and managers
to the executives and even michael
himself had become complacent they
thought that they had made it and that
they were safe
but as dove story shows us there's no
such thing as making it the second that
one thinks they made it is the second
they lose the lead even decades a
flawless execution can be unraveled
within just a few short years and the
recovery if there is one will be just as
hard as the first time around the thing
to keep in mind in such situations is
that a 100 return is required to
counteract a 50 decline
so be sure that you're not the one who's
caught being complacent did you guys
know about the roller coaster ride dell
went on comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that dell
teaches all of us a valuable lesson
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you